now the bite administration is on the
ropes desean and i just talked about and
it's going to use just about any
possible excuse it can find to change
the subject and then silence its critics
now let's just walk past down memory
lane first they used the riots of
january 6
as a justification to fence off the
capital with razor wire they did this
for several months by the way costing us
tens of millions of dollars i don't even
think we know the final amount the fbi
treated ordinary citizens who weren't
part of any violence at all at the
capitol as dangerous insurrectionists
and domestic terrorists
second they used covid
to villainize medical professionals who
were actually treating covet patients
who also saw right through tony fauchi's
bureaucratic blather and the cdc's
cherry picked data
remember our medicine cabinet knew for
two years that lockdowns were just going
to prolong the pandemic and closing the
schools was going to end up destroying
kids lives
doctors who questioned biden and all of
the medical experts that were touted on
television every day from the left
well the doctors who actually knew what
they were doing had their livelihoods
threatened
in the end though we were right and the
mandates are finally being lifted
now obviously neither of those topics
work to turn americans attention away
from biden's mounting domestic problems
of crime inflation high energy prices
and at open border
a wall of opposition is building against
democrats nationwide
now remember virginia parents they
elected glenn yonkin after seeing that
the teachers unions were really the ones
in charge in education and in that world
aristotle loses out to ibram kennedy and
george washington's just not as
important as george floyd
now this is going to flatten the
democrats this fall
and i think
they know it
so this leaves democrats with no other
choices this election season but to go
with the golden oldie so forget about
the gas closing in on five bucks a
gallon because is on the move
we're united in our understanding of the
urgency and seriousness of the threat
russia is making to global peace and
stability this is
the greatest threat to security in
europe since world war ii
ukraine is in danger
president putin is blatantly and
violently breaking the laws i mean
listen guys
we're talking about the potential for
war in europe
i mean let's really take a moment to
understand the significance of what
we're talking about
do any of these people really care about
ukraine and russia now remember not long
ago obama talked about he wanted to make
deals with russia and then he made fun
of romney for sounding the alarm on
putin
a few months ago when you were asked
what's the biggest geopolitical threat
facing america you said russia
not al qaeda you said russia and the
1980s are now
calling to ask for their foreign policy
back because you know the cold war has
been over for 20 years
the democrats don't care about russia
they never have
they care about holding on to power at
all costs
they certainly didn't care about russia
when the soviet union was actually a
real threat to the united states in the
1980s
but now that russia has an economy about
the size of italy's they care
so how did we get here
well the answer believe it or not lies
over in china which has now become
russia's biggest booster in this current
conflict
for two decades elites here in the
united states thought it was a good idea
to build up china make them richer and
more powerful even
biden not only thought it but he said it
but a rising china is a positive
positive development
not only for china but for america and
the world writ large
and now china has all it needs to prop
up russia no matter what putin does in
ukraine
by not only got a rising china they're
poised to surpass the united states
economically and already have a larger
standing army than we do
so to the extent that russia is any real
threat today it's only because china is
standing beside them
biden promised he was going to return us
didn't he to our proper standing in the
global community the rules-based
international order and that he was
going to be a unifying force around the
world remember that
but after one year he's weakened america
and he's united our enemies quite an
accomplishment
mark my words
as long as china is perceived as the
most powerful country in the world
the us is going to have a tough time
campaigning someone like putin
rather than figuring out ways to make
china weaker and unite america
biden and the hill democrats are looking
for new villains here at home
searching for a strategy to avoid a 2020
midterm disaster advisers to president
biden have discussed elevating a
unifying republican foil not named
donald trump that was from axios today
now that political sage from the islands
mazie hirono told axios i wish that we
could just find one face that we could
point to such as with donald trump maybe
a composite
i'd like us to do a much more effective
job of really drawing the contrast
between republicans and democrats
now one idea being considered is to
substitute trump with fox news
these right-wing pundits and the the gop
that supports him really frankly have
blood on their hands what does it say
that you have people like tucker carlson
and fox news drumming up support for
putin
yeah i mean look it's not frustrating
it's sickening uh it's un-american
tucker carlson is one of the most
dangerous people alive right now
actually the voices of the newly
radicalized gop they're all on the putin
train
they're on the putin train
and the once respected harvard law
professor liberal larry tribe has gone
full despot tweeting then deleting this
led by fox news channel's tucker carlson
the gop's trump wing appears to be
throwing its weight behind putin if
putin opts to wage war on our ally
ukraine such aid and comfort to an enemy
would appear to become treason as
defined by article 3 of the us
constitution by the way he actually i
think wrote a constitutional law
textbook it's in our law schools right
now
but of course this isn't about silencing
critics is it no
calling them traitors or questioning
whether inching toward war with russia
is the right choice now perhaps larry
spent too much time in cambridge but the
entire populist conservative movement
was based on the idea of making america
so strong economically
that it would be able to avoid future
wars or conflicts
but now they have a mumbling imbecile at
the white house bumbling us toward
conflict and they turn around try to
blame us for it nice try
our nation of course remains exceptional
but we've been debilitated by two wars
that we didn't win and now we're sitting
on 30 trillion dollars of debt
republicans and democrats both
responsible for that
but as long as the u.s stays weak
economically
the world will become a harsher and far
more cruel place
that's news to the left which has spent
the last 15 years attacking our middle
middle class
rather than trying to fix big problems
and make america better
they just use this as an opportunity to
demonize their political adversaries
now think about the stupidity of this
we're on the verge of war
and we still have the same military
leadership in place
who couldn't get us out of afghanistan
the right way
that's brilliant and we're on the verge
of war and our trade policies are still
making china russia's new strong friend
richer by the day
biden has driven our energy prices
higher by limiting domestic drilling
and who benefits from that
not us
putin does
every time oil prices go up and biden's
supporters remember love high energy
costs their climate crazy
russia has more money in its pocket to
fund his military ambitions putin's
happy
yesterday it was trump the villain they
could run against then it was january 6
then it was covid then the parents
protesting at school board meetings and
now it's russia and fox news
but the important thing to remember in
all of this
is that after 25 years of establishment
leadership except for the four years of
donald trump who got it right
america is dramatically weaker
so going forward it's the job of our
leaders to fix america rebuild the
military culture and find a way to get
more leverage over china
meanwhile
the democrats
are slowly committing political suicide
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else